this episode brought to you by skill
share classes taught by expert
practitioners for your career or for
your passions the first 500 people who
sign up receive a free two-month trial
wonderful bring in the RoboCup script
reduce the Artwalk EG 13 wasn't it being
our what sucked people in well yeah but
being pg-13 allows more people to see it
even though more people won't want to
see it cuz it's pg-13 it made more sense
when the chart guy said it I thought we
said no new ideas well we have to do
something different or we might as well
be a Disney remake different scares
people you scare people so the focus
groups tell me alright well start with
new ideas and then never go anywhere
with them that way everybody loses are
you sure that's how studio's making
money
well the chart says good news we have
Samuel Jackson perfect he's gonna be an
amazing Robocop actually he's only in
for a few minutes oh who do we have to
play Robocop that boring guy from
Suicide Squad which one never mind just
go ahead with this not gonna make
character ever matters you're gonna be a
money-making motherfucker
yeah but not you because you're gonna be
amazing people never forget about hey
when are you guys gonna get to making my
sequel
oh sorry of Robocop movie that's not
gonna happen yeah we're working on how
to make money with another Pixar sequel
good dinosaur - I forgot there was a
condensed or one oh hey come on
there is still potential yeah critically
you weren't that big ahead and
domestically you made only a little over
half your money back but 49 percent on
Rotten Tomatoes that's almost half and I
did good on a worldwide release just
like alien 3 and Warcraft
those are the examples you went with
come on just think of the Ghostbuster
reboot attack Total Recall reboot
Fantastic Four Lone Ranger that Tom
Cruise mummy movie this is embarrassing
for you Oh God how did things go so
wrong I guess it was kind of inevitable
when you remake something so unique and
beloved wait how are you reviewing me if
you also somehow made me do I segue that
makes sense or a review which ever
doesn't crap on mean they bout to throw
Robocop was a gigantic eighties hit it
had big action bloody gore in-your-face
commentary and somebody losing their job
for this effect the movie was so beloved
that years later Detroit decide to make
a Robocop statue holy shit I fight that
for a dollar it was crazy
awesome crazy awesome so naturally they
had to reboot it
in 2014 the director of elite squad give
us a slightly different look at the
action icon you failed to grab audiences
and critics was forgotten fairly quickly
but looking back with this a valiant
effort that only had a glitch or was it
a valiant effort that only had this
glitch you called this a glitch well
we're here to take a closer look let's
try our best to give this movie our
cooperation our soak through and in the
movie that's kind of cool right you need
to stop but alright this is Robocop 2014
so let's see how this dark and gritty
reboot gets things going this time he's
a pigeon it turns out this is Samuel
Jackson doing vocal warm-ups
let's be honest though if you want a
more fitting Jackson quote to start this
movie off you'd be like shame fuck you
he plays a commentator named Pat Novak
which sounds like a fox news anchor who
got fired for groping too much or not
enough what if I told you that even the
worst neighborhood in America could be
made completely safe he's behind a big
movement to replace cops and soldiers
with machines as demonstrated with this
live takedown in Iran they're the big
boys they secure the perimeter
it is great to see American machines
helping to blow peace and freedom we
could find out what's in your Safa kiss
but it looks like suicide bombers are
ready to take them out starting off
light I see but I'm worried about the
question issue television living under
the Bombers attack
yeah I'm positive the best way to start
this movie off was wish but the original
Robocop was dark and bloody yeah but
that was over-the-top criminals and
comic-book thugs this is frickin suicide
bombers in the Middle East I mean I
guess if it ties in to the rest of the
story it makes sense but we never come
back to it this is the only scene in
Iran so what's the point in showing this
disturbing overseas warfare it's just
uncomfortable imagine if you were
watching the cartoon and they were
suddenly like I'm not wish to see Lewis
hurt because of me so you do have
feelings for me it gives me flashbacks
to the religious jihadis I had to kill
because they claimed countless American
lives
if only political strategists could
figure out how to wash the blood from my
soul by my toys I would watch that and
buy his toys for security reasons the
Pentagon's going to cut our feed
yeah she did on the one hand we have
Raymond Sellars wow that's amazing
the film's coolness levels went up by 20
percent by simply putting Michael Keaton
and Samuel Jackson on the same screen
but what do you expect when they come
from this kid so we cut to our main
character Murphy played by Joe Kinmen at
least I think it's him it's hard to tell
if the cameras shaking so much that's
nothing personal you've got to be dumb
or dirty
maybe if you hadn't gone off the
reservation your partner it'd still be
standing weekend this time
it's without a tripod and I can't really
tell has he become the emotionless robot
yet I mean Jack we've been doing some
Street buys we got some problems back
home with Chicago PD I'm gonna go hard
nothing like a madness my father's ain't
even been there
it's not like the original Murphy was
Robert E friggin Niro there's some truth
to that
the idea behind Murphy and the first
ones we saw him mostly as the machine
and we found out more about connection
to his family as it moved on he created
a little bit of a mystery to his
humanity revealing how soft and
sentimental he really was yes in my
version you see him with the family
early on
and you suck at only from every
conceivable angle in this version the
scenes with him and the family are
boring as sin
there's no playfulness no energy no
joking around he's just the same overly
serious stick-in-the-mud as in all the
other scenes this was a chance to really
add to his personal life really explore
his humanity but you just keep him stiff
and bland hey guys
just because he's like an extra in those
Street movies Mark Wahlberg does in his
spare time doesn't mean he's not deep
couldn't you haven't smile at least once
or maybe tell a joke okay how's this for
a joke why did the chicken cross the
road I don't know to get to the
pretentious assholes house knock knock
who's there
the chicken I'm sorry I just wanted to
remind people I was still here
so Keaton plays the head of Omnicorp
please no accent please no accent please
no access I need to give Americans a
product they can love oh thank Christ as
this analyst tries to work out a way to
win the government and the public over
to expand the machines to what Jay
Baruchel in the role it sounds like
they're trying to figure out how to save
DreamWorks Animation my team have come
up with a pretty aggressive new campaign
it's not another How to Train Your
Dragon is it how - of course not they
want a product the conscience I'm sorry
I can't hear a thing over your paintings
how am I supposed to not focus on that
can't even show those on YouTube means a
machine they decide to add a human touch
boy are you in the wrong film for that
as they go to a doctor who specializes
in robotic limbs for amputees
Commissioner Gordon Batman
Keaton fills him in on the plan and all
they're looking for now is the perfect
subject to give up all human emotion
hello
Wow that would have been really
surprising and effective if we didn't
see them plant the bond there earlier
takes away a little bit from the shock
doesn't it once you just start off the
sixth sense with Haley Joel Osment
saying hi dad as you can see Murphy's
lost two limbs has burns all over his
body but somehow his face actually looks
better than before the accident damn I
wish my car would blow up so I could
clear out my pores
it's you they put him in his Robo body
but he doesn't react well to it clearly
we picked the right test subject to be
fair who'd have thought he had a
personality to wake what scientific
theory backed that dumb move let him
roam through our highly expensive
equipment in an unstoppable killer suit
immediately after choking me I'm sure
the little scamp will Tucker himself out
ah this is where they make those
Japanese Robocop commercials oh look at
him ride the kitchen
fear not though look a doctor it's a
foolproof way to prevent this from going
any further please stop
stay where you are thank you
Alex don't make me say please do I have
to count to twenty two thousand four
hundred eighty-two definitely there's a
way to shut him down
Robo crop this time it's really hard to
make a joke about this one did the
movies credit we do get the only
nightmarish moment I could see being in
the original when they show how much of
his human body is actually left because
there's nothing left your body may have
gone but you're still here you're still
the same boring dumbass you always were
you're in control then I want to die but
what do I say to your wife what does she
say to your son I died I guess Murphy's
kind of a dick in this version I mean
god so much of the original was him
trying to remember and reconnect with
his family but here just tell him I died
no more parent-teacher conferences am i
right I guess the idea is his family
meant so much he couldn't stand the idea
of them seeing him like that but a
because it was so lifeless we never
really got an idea of what his family
life was like be if you'll love each
other you should be happy to see one
another no matter what the circumstance
and see the circumstances kind of forget
awesome you have a bulletproof body your
kid will always have a giant action
figure to play with and if they did
their job right so will your wife it
seems like more pros than cons this time
there's a family plan we're gonna get
through this baby
we're gonna make it like it was you know
can you really take this scene that
seriously with that kids picture there
of all the ones to pick in a dramatic
moment that's the one you went with he's
looking at him like bubble cap you
cray-cray he looks like he should have
meme text under him Moyes entity person
let's give him a nice hook him up with
that TX crumpet from Terminator 3 they
test him in a simulation to see how he
handles a crime scene compared to a
robot
I do give credit I feel like the
original director of air hoping would
have played the Tin Man song here too
but I think we all know he used this
line differently five point six seconds
behind scenario failure you wouldn't buy
that for a dollar Oh piss off hey you
want a side-by-side comparison let's try
that scene which would you rather see
the rest of wouldn't buy that for a
dollar coincidentally neither would Best
Buy murphy decides to search the
internet so he uses Bing I take it back
this movie has a better sense of humor
than I thought to find out more about
the people who did this to him detective
Murphy was simply overzealous okay we
have absolutely no evidence linking
balance of the attempt in his life you
know why are they let him search for
stuff that could upset him you saw what
the mere act of waking him did how is
this gonna balance out it's about as
consistent as the sunlight in that back
window that Sun is not a cooperative
actor Keaton sees Robocop's delays in
the side-by-side comparison it says
exactly what the makers of fall assembly
6 said while in development when I have
got a release date we've gotta make it
okay I don't care how you do it come on
can you help me get it fixed I don't
care how you do it just go do it a
moment of silence for those who
pre-ordered that so they make some
literal mental notes
I'm gonna put you to sleep top oh yeah I
was gonna ask why you didn't do that
before oh I'm gonna fix it rated pg-13
it says alien vs. predator the Dark
Knight the Last Crusade drag me to hell
ratings are a joke it really put the
fear of God into the prisoners let's go
with black it's cuz your Batman is yeah
cuz I'm Batman
so they paint in black which is a shame
because aside from the visor that looks
like a darkwing duck henchman the suit
actually looked pretty good but now it
just looks like Christopher Nolan
directing the tick it's just bland and
forgettable they finally put him to the
test against both robots and people
trying to take him down by God is this
that thing the other Robocop movies
called action and this seems a little
off though when you hear the musical
choice
he'll kind of selection is that you'll
don't come this time it's in the middle
of the simulation they drop an
interesting concept system releases
signals into Alex's brain making him to
think he's doing what our computers are
actually I mean out exploring is right
now he is in control but he's not it's
the illusion of free will like you think
if you don't go see this film they're
gonna start making original movies again
he passes the test with flying colors
that is if this movie had any other
colors apart from brown and you finally
decides he's ready to see his family
have you heard the Robo news Omni Corp
saves I was gonna ask you if you were
say or counter but I thought that one
was funny or had seriously I miss to you
know I miss you buddy
please doubt the rush of emotion is
overwhelming saved all the right wing
schemes in my compare you did oh it's a
smile don't fly off the handle like that
buddy keep it together how did you went
home already sorry yeah no yeah I forgot
he had a partner remember what a big
role the partner played in the first one
one of the big connections back to his
personality his soul his work his
humanity now here it's just a couple of
lines like yes I know you the right
color now you look like the Mega Man
version of get out so the big premiere
day arrives and only now do they decide
to do this procedure that could screw
everything up I think it's gonna screw
everything up we're gonna upload the
entire DPD database and do your brain
what is this that's his
weird he's going to pieces while
watching himself literally go to pieces
I'm so glad we showed him this before he
went public his mind is out of control
so they decide to take out his emotions
to pretty much make him like the
original Robocop I feel fine but more so
yeah all those cool scenarios that could
have been played out figuring out who's
making the choices and an ER machine
recycle bin that shit it's just a
machine now Christ why did you just
start off with that like in the original
if you're not gonna do anything with
this concept his emotional journey
wasn't that interesting because you know
you need a motion and now there's no
question whether or not it's the man or
the machine making the choices we just
know it's the machine except for the
obvious stuff we know is coming where
the human part is gonna take control
again how much more interesting would it
be if like in this scene from the
original you had the question was that
the coldness of the machine or the
coldness of the human you don't really
know it's kind of up for you to decide
what's the first time didn't introduce
that option this one did and they're not
doing anything with it damn it this
could have been an interesting story
about choice
a Detroit becoming Robocop if you will
but it's all thrown out for a simplified
version of the original where he just
talks like a robot and captures
criminals
tomah's King you're under arrest in fact
he even captures a rapist at the
premiere because he recognized him from
the police files here is just steps away
from two of Detroit's finest you know
that's another thing the commentary in
this sucks - in the other film the
environment is insane and rotten and
greedy and we see it through all these
newscasters it's like a cinematic
version of the media from Dark Knight
Returns but here is just one guy one guy
that's the world-building that's just
one guy that's like saying we know what
the world is like by only listening to
Bill Maher whoo I didn't know the world
didn't give a shit about Stanley good
thing we had this totally balanced
source to go off of don't you see it's a
satire of extreme points of view like
CNN MSNBC or the Disney Channel then why
don't you have more than
one point of view how much more
interesting with this film be if it
incorporated new developments like
social media message boards phone apps
in the over 27 years since the last one
came out you could have taken this in so
many different directions but somehow
you actually do less than what the
original film did well what would they
say hey why did that criminal on the run
show up to an event filled with cops
with cops
no I think I'm pointing that way
Jarrett it's okay he's not smart enough
to realize he should have ran away
they say you can't teach an old dog new
tricks well that's a Doug in my late 30s
I take offense at Beth I can teach
myself lots of new tricks for example I
just taught myself how to play the
guitar ok it is difficult to teach an
old dog new tricks but with skill chair
it's not as difficult skill chair is an
online learning community for creators
with more than 25,000 classes and design
business and more whether you want to
fuel your curiosity creativity or even
career skills share is the perfect place
to keep you learning and thriving in
2019 if you do Premium Membership you
get unlimited access so you can join the
classes and communities that are right
for you and your new year goals there's
a ton of software I never knew how to
use but now I can because of the site so
I can edit faster draw faster everything
is more efficient and yes they even have
guitar classes though I may want to give
up on that one skill chair is also super
affordable an annual subscription is
less than ten dollars a month and the
first 500 of my subscribers to use the
link in the description will get a two
month free trial that's right a two
month free trial just click on the link
below to get started so join the over 7
million creators out there that are
learning with skill share it's a new
year so might as well started off
learning new things click on the link
below to get your 2 month free trial
today skill share so much to learn so
much time
so just a mere hour and 10 minutes in
Robocop finally takes to the streets to
fight some criminals
you know I gotta hand it to you movie
the crime-fighting scenes actually
aren't that bad it's shot nice it looks
cool it's cleverly done thank you
I know it must have been hard for you to
like something I especially like that
bike he's writing didn't Omnicorp give
him that actually that's his penis oh
it's as the saying goes once you go
black you will probably be injured
because there's giant wheels on you I
was unaware of that version thank you
and Pia Murphy's wife tries to talk with
him but robotic side takes control yeah
I think again it's hard to tell
sometimes
klaren please stand aside you need to
speak to your son right now I see three
crimes in progress
lazy riding tall to writing and stilted
acting I'll let me at that last one was
me but he decides to go to his old home
to figure out if he can solve the
mystery of the bomb he'll I already saw
that lazy riding doll directing and
stilted acting
debo cop this time just don't get it
man I even blow up oaring he's I'm doing
what scripts to try to go into it so
we'll just say love his mission is now
clear as he sets out for revenge
now I hope I can beat my high score yeah
at this point all you can think about is
how awesome this would be if it was a
gate actually yeah would be if this was
an updated Robocop game in 2014 and it
was about choice as well as action no
joke this will probably be a much better
product imagine the scene where he finds
out his own unit caused the car bomb as
a movie it's nothing but how much more
shocking would it be if it happened to
you in a game you figured it out for
yourself and you have a choice what to
do about it you tipped him off today you
try to kill me twice but it's not a game
it's just a dumb movie so they shut him
down and make eating the easy bad guy
whoa didn't see that coming what's
bigger than a hero I don't know I don't
have a say in which chart in front of me
dead hero now the audience response to
this disagrees so keen as the good
doctor to kill the fallen Robocop I
won't fall funny ten years new staff on
my own people
deal yeah they're really gonna make old
men the bad guy
hey on top of that I hear this guy has
it in for Pinocchio what a shock Oldman
fries Murphy but Keaton tells his wife
that he's dead tennis psychotic break he
killed an unarmed colleague we did
everything everything you know I can see
why he was Birdman and vulture his
movements are very foul like had a
psychotic break
oh he killed a colleague we did
everything everything we could doctors
couldn't save him we're going to be
making the announcement shortly
this time it was just too good not to
use again she believes in though as he
gets ready to announce it to the news
look at this city so beautiful
I have very sad news Alex Murphy passed
away just hours ago starts off a news
announcement like that I don't care what
you're announcing that's just weird
imagine if I was like look at this town
so grand so open so unassuming I have
some sad tragic news the IHOP down the
street closed Robocop Burson the Omni
Corp to discover oh yeah those things
were in the movie - Frank know he wants
us to do this damn it Frank you're off
the Christmas card list
I guess that is a more impressive take
down that stairs what was that
Robocop makes it to the top of the
building where his wife and kid are
buddies program not to kill kita if you
go against the program the entire system
shuts down oh you don't even have a
warrant
now I'm sorry I can't hear anything over
that intense Detroit wind being so high
up on a building it's just so loud and
blowing everyone's hair around
Who am I kidding I wish I couldn't hear
it's I didn't have to listen to
callbacks like this because I'm the only
one with the technology to keep you
alive Dead or Alive you're coming with
me
does that even make sense in this one if
I'm dead or alive you're coming with me
as my corpse gonna rest you but Keaton
isn't done well Keating if I wanted to I
could have killed you a long time ago I
just named this ready Dredd I mean if I
wanted to like just saying the secure
little family I could just kill them too
you know it's kind of like a male Ellen
thing you know just little spurts and
the hands and just saying was obviously
going on these little spurts and hands
and just saying what's obviously going
out these little spurts and had oh now
I'm shot just gonna lay here on the
ground and anticlimactic at least my
arms are the same size what the hell was
that
you know Keenan's character really was
so odd and eccentric where do you think
a guy like that goes when he dies Murphy
of course ends up surviving and may even
give him back his old color suit
oh hey better close that door so we
don't get any accidental emotion in this
oh come on I was just kidding they're
really doing that you're not even gonna
show a hug emotions it can be a thing it
ends with the law being changed about
machines which ignites Nick furious
anger the fact that this mother is not
serving bullshit it's pg-13 you can get
one f-bomb you took away Samuel
Jackson's one that Bob you know the real
nightmares futures the one that has I'm
talking like this pg-13 Robocop so okay
this is not a good remake or reboot but
I'd be lying if I said it was as bad as
I thought it would be the supporting
cast is mostly good the ideas are
interesting starts and it made me
realize this could be taken in different
directions hell it can even kind of
start in a different direction by
showing Murphy's emotional side early
but the emotional stuff is just not well
done this movie either needed a lot more
over-the-top insanity to top the
original a lot more hard to make it more
emotional and or just follow through
with its ideas as is it's just another
remake that's already being forgotten
and it's a shame because I see now it
could have been something really cool if
there was just a touch more creative
cooperation in the end it's just a robo
mess now if you'll excuse us we're gonna
try and figure out another clumsy
money-making scheme so I guess I am
totally useless surely there must be
something I can do to prove my worth I
know why don't I find Malcolm he has
been gone for some time hasn't he movie
I thought you understood
you are Malcolm what
he was mailed to us in several different
parts so we figured instead of putting
him back together again we'll make him
into something new wait you brought me
back to life as a Robocop movie don't
act like you haven't tried that nobody
has right back
and since you didn't make back your
money I suppose we can give you back
your memory and put you back together
the way you were will I remember any of
this do you remember any of the Robocop
reboot we just reviewed it and I can't
remember okay sounds about right
I'm gonna stab the critic I remembered
because who the hell remembers the
Robocop reboot planes three there are
planes too what the fuck is planes
hey dub Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
fistula foundation fistula is the
disease in many developing countries
that affects pregnant women
sadly in many countries these women are
outcast and shamed by their society but
the fistula foundation can help they
believe no woman should endure a life of
misery and isolation simply for trying
to bring a child into the world that's
why they're dedicated to ending the
suffering caused by this as it's an
injury that can be treated through
surgery through their generous donors
they provide human and financial
resources that enable as many women as
possible to receive the treatment they
need every site they fund is coordinated
and staffed by local nurses and trained
doctors who understand the community and
how to provide the best care possible to
the women they treat if you look at
their site in their YouTube channel you
can see all the women that have been
held by this organization and all the
good people who have helped give them
their lives back click on the link and
see what you can do to help these women
live their normal lives
you